Pete's dragon is Disney's newest
live-action attempt to remake one of
their properties recently Cinderella and
especially the Jungle Book were very
good and I think pretty much universally
loved by fans so I was excited to see if
that success could carry over to one of
the more lesser-known stories in this
film you have a boy who loses his family
tragically at a very young age and his
adopted sort of by a dragon in a forest
that he name's Elliott and he spends the
next six years of his life being raised
by that dragon in the forest but when he
gets a little bit older and is
eventually discovered by Bryce Dallas
Howard who plays a park ranger in this
movie
that's where things get a little bit
dramatic and a little bit Disney five
Pete's dragon is in my opinion a pretty
good movie it's not great it is getting
really good reviews but I would say that
it just really isn't as good as I wanted
it to be although I did like it this is
by no means a boring film this is by no
means a poorly acted movie and it's very
beautiful to look at the dragon itself
is a wonder of a creation through CGI
it's not quite as impressive or
realistic as the Jungle Book animals
earlier this year which were almost
photorealistic and truly mind-blowing
but the CG here does work really well
and the dragon itself is just adorable I
can't imagine someone watching this
movie and not being like I would like to
fly in the sky with you because you are
just a beautiful thing the lead boy in
this film Pete just wasn't quite as
compelling of a hero as I wanted him to
be I think the film struggles to have
one real protagonist because you have
Robert Redford in this movie talking
about having seen this dragon at one
point in time and that's how the movie
begins with his narration and then you
have Bryce Dallas Howard who finds him
and the movie is called Pete's dragon so
you're assuming that he's the main
character but the movie kind of goes
back and forth between who to follow
you also have Karl Urban in this film
who plays someone who feels the Dragons
out there and wants to hunt it down and
so you have all these characters and
most of the time they're fleshed out
fairly well I'm just saying the movie
has a tough time really identifying with
one of them the young boy playing Pete
is fine there's nothing wrong with his
performance it's just that he was
nowhere near as compelling as say Mowgli
in the
Jungle Book he's just there wasn't that
much about him beyond the sadness of
what happened to his family because once
he got separated from the dragon for me
the movie slowed down a little bit and
it takes a while for it to pick back up
but I still really enjoyed this film as
pure family entertainment I think a lot
of kids will really enjoy it but it's
just not quite as compelling or exciting
as I was expecting it to be it is a very
good looking movie and very well acted
with a very good musical score and
overall I really think families are
going to have a good time with Pete's
dragon and I'm going to give it a
b-minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I still have one more video
coming for you this weekend that of
blood father I'm going to review that
very soon you guys are the best thank
you once again and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes